-Welcome back. The one and only
Elton John is joining us.
We love you!
[ Cheers and applause ]
The new album,
"The Lockdown Sessions,"
is out now.
Did you ever think
such a shy child would end up
being you, Elton John?
[ Light laughter ]
-[ Laughs ]
Never in a million years
could I have expected
what's happened to me
in my lifetime, Jimmy.
-Really?
-The fact that I was a child
and I was a very shy child
when I started playing
the piano, and it's all
down to Jerry Lee Lewis
and Little Richard.
When they started jumping up and
down and playing it standing up,
then that changed my whole life
completely.
And that's what I wanted to do
and I wanted to make music.
I didn't ever intend
to become Elton John.
I just wanted to be involved
in music and play it.
And I got gratification from
that and love from doing that.
-Yeah.
-And so, I thought, yeah.
This is -- I like this.
-Yeah, well, you did it better
than most people.
I want to say, your "Farewell
Yellow Brick Road Tour,"
I was ready to go see you.
'cause this is
your farewell tour.
It got cut short
because of the pandemic,
and also maybe a sign that we
don't want you to say farewell.
[ Cheers and applause ]
We want you to keep going.
Don't stop!
But you're coming back.
-Yeah, I'm coming back
to New Orleans in January.
I've just had my hip replaced,
on the right leg.
So I'm rehabbing in London
at the moment.
And it's all going well,
and I just wanted to make sure
that I could actually
get through the whole tour.
Because before the operation,
I don't think
I would have been able to.
So, we pushed some dates back,
and I start again
in New Orleans.
And I cannot wait,
because we were here,
we were roaring
like an express train.
-Yeah.
-And then, of course, COVID hit.
And everyone was just
ground to a halt.
But I did a concert
in Paris recently
in front of 20,000 people.
And I haven't played a concert
in front of that kind of crowd
since March the 7th, 2020.
And it felt really good.
And, you know, I love my fans
and I want to go out
and give them
the best thing possible,
and you know, I can't wait.
-Yeah.
For a lot of people, this will
be their first concert back.
I mean, if you go
to eltonjohn.com,
if you want to see Elton,
you're coming to New York,
February 22nd and 23rd
at the Garden.
Madison Square Garden.
You're also playing
Barclays Center in March.
But Madison Square Garden
and Elton John go together
like peanut butter and jelly.
I mean, it's the greatest
combination.
We -- New Yorkers love you.
-Well, you know,
I have to say New York is,
Madison Square Garden
in particular
is the finest place to play
in the world.
I mean, you get really excited.
You never lose the excitement
of going backstage
and playing to that crowd.
I've done so many memorable
concerts there.
I played my 60th birthday
concert there,
the concert for 9/11.
-Yeah.
-And there's something about
that New York crowd
that's just quite astonishing.
And I've never done a show
at Madison Square Garden
where I didn't think --
it didn't do well.
And, you know,
it's a magic place.
I'm so glad they never moved it.
Because if they'd have moved it,
the atmosphere would have gone.
It's just a magic place.
-Yeah, the house
has good bones, yeah.
-It's great in New York because
New York's a magic place
and you got the best show in
the world right in front of you.
[ Applause ]
-I want to ask you --
I've always wanted to ask you
this story about -- 'cause
I've always heard this story,
but about John Lennon performing
with you at the Garden.
He -- This is post-Beatles.
I think, actually,
it might've been the last time
he played live.
-It was.
-You had a bet with John.
-Yeah, well,
I played on John's record
"Whatever Gets You Thru
the Night," and sang on it too.
And I said, "Okay, if this
record gets to number one,
you've got to come on,
play live with them."
And he said, "Okay, you're on."
And by Jove,
it did get to number one,
and then he had to keep
his promise, which he did,
at Madison Square Garden
on Thanksgiving.
And it was one of the most
magical moments in my life.
Probably for me, the memory of
him coming onstage
and getting so much applause,
I think all the band, and
myself, were moved to tears.
And it was such
a wonderful occasion.
I don't think
he'd played in New York
since the Beatles
at Shea Stadium.
-Yeah, that's correct.
-And it just --
You know, it was just
a magical moment in one's life
to see someone so loved
getting that so much acclaim.
And, you know, I had
such a great time with John
for two years,
and it's one of the highlights
of my life and my career.
-I can't wait to see you
when you come back around.
I will be screaming
from the crowd.
I love you.
Elton John, everybody.
"The Lockdown Sessions"
is available now.